the Joe Rogan experience realistic body
types yeah yeah like this is a thing
that gets brought up all the time okay
maybe but they've even had these promos
and these advertisements taken down
particularly in the UK there was a big
story about that because they were
promoting unrealistic body types okay
one of those guys try to do that to one
of those Vox guys is this a Bible it was
trying it no it's not I'm trying to like
say don't follow these gate is it he's a
gay guy who's saying don't follow these
gay Instagram thirst pages because
they're promoting an unrealistic body
type and [ __ ] gay guys just attacked
the probably had a shut his [ __ ]
Instagram down for a while because play
with that [ __ ] I don't like that
unrealistic body type you could pull
that off on some women though yeah it's
unrealistic yeah but it's not
unrealistic that's a real woman oh yeah
it's just not your body or it's not
typical well look if you're a [ __ ] a
person i'm 5-8 if I look at a LeBron
James 7-foot tall man well that's an
unrealistic body type no it's realistic
yeah play a basketball professionally
he's a real person yeah [ __ ] Holly is
that unrealistic
it's just unachievable for me that's
just this is what it is
right that's what that's what you got
that's the [ __ ] hand you got yeah
nothing to do with realistic or
unrealistic if you see a girl and she's
got a tiny waist and a big ass and big
tits she's just got that Jennifer Lopez
Jean [ __ ] yeah that's just her she got
lucky you didn't get that lucky that is
realistic yeah
now if they're using that to sell
[ __ ] Fanta or Adidas shoes or
whatever the [ __ ] it is so what if
you're saying well all these girls feel
terrible because that's unrealistic
that's life that is that is life yeah
that again we come back we come back to
why are we responsible for everyone's
feelings forget get off the [ __ ]
couch and go do something about it if
you don't if you don't want to if you
don't want to feel sad no one cares
about though fat dudes fat dude [ __ ] off
no one cares no one feels bad about fat
dude well they get away with the whole
dad bod thing which I wrote a whole
piece about guys that got like burgers
pods that bod dad bot isn't an excuse to
be lazy though I know some guys do a
lean really into that they're like it's
a dad but I'm like and they're like they
like it yeah they kind of get away with
it
cuz it's like you know guys get like
cute adorable little dad bod and women
get like Fupa
I don't think so though no girl wants a
dad bod do you think the reason why
woman dad Baz cuz they know that the guy
has like glass options he's more likely
to stick around right okay it's good dad
files like where you going [ __ ] or I'm
gonna [ __ ] you either one but I mean
look I'm sure some women were three guys
they like yes yes and I think some women
like more like girth and me like a
little bit of weight yeah yeah some
girls like big thick women - everybody's
different everybody I just think that if
you like somebody that's here to your
point is that it's fine whatever you
like whatever your type is if you're
into like a big dude if you're at
whatever but the people who like people
who are fit are somehow not mean shame
only thing that's changed is people's
ability to express themselves online
through social media that's the only
thing that's changed and because of that
people are yelling about things that
don't that that they can't do do you get
fit shame hit odd you called a meathead
I guess that's fit change yeah yeah
discharged yeah I don't care but if
you're ashamed me for being in shape
like congratulations
okay I don't care it doesn't work yeah
what do you feel great
thank you for being successful oh you
got me sorry sorry I figured out a lot
of [ __ ] it's such a weird this is a
weird the weird world is that it feels
like we're raising the you know where
the bar isn't it's being lowered and
lowered and lowered and so instead of
raising our standards and trying to
everybody lift each other up it's more
just like a very small majority that's
like calm down but again it's a tiny
amount of but it had we've been talking
about it it has an outsized influence
well it has people reacting to it
they're bending towards it but I think
it's it's temporary
yes look you're optimistic you think
it's gonna like eat its own tail like
that where's Bora Bora should never be
woken up yeah each other they turn on
each other this I don't think it's real
I don't think it's real yeah look
they're certain but the people always
are gonna like and there's certain
things that men are gonna like certain
things that women are gonna like it's
just it's just the way it is I do think
it gets sorted pretty quickly like in in
in natural disasters you know I always
say this I'm like you call yourself
whatever you want and the other
interesting thing is you know your
computer knows better than you whatever
you're saying online yeah they've done
studies and it's like it doesn't matter
what you're saying online your search
engine knows what gender you are
essentially yeah I mean it can generally
tell like probably with a large accuracy
search results you'll be [ __ ] super
obviously but I think that we just live
in this really confusing moment in
history
so I guess my fear is that the there's
the the youth are in ingesting all this
kind of confusing for them yeah it is it
is but it's also theirs look as much as
I like to make fun of world culture the
good thing about is is making people
more sensitive high grades making people
nicer yeah but not not necessarily nicer
because so many people that Alok are
using that as an excuse to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to people right to force
compliance would be an [ __ ] but
because of that because of that it's
again it's like the tide and stand out
and it's it's gonna find its healthy
level
[Applause]